[Applaudissements]
voilà tous les ennemis de syrie jean paf
ils sont prêts à nous soutenir le stade
ou soutenir un même casimir un gros
bonhomme orange
j'aurais pas soupçonner ça de lui bon
ben maintenant reste plus qu'à trouver
quelqu'un qui soit de notre côté et
qu'ils le fassent partir de l'es8 las
jay automne j'ai trouvé lemoine jean luc
non le tremblement annie non troisième
le moins de babette anne elisabeth
lemoine lumière tous les étages pour
touche pas à mon poste je pense qu'il
n'a jamais vraiment proposer mons et on
sait déjà du plein de fois qu'on
aimerait travailler ensemble ou qu'il
aimerait produire une émission dans
laquelle dans laquelle je suis un
sapristi merci pour document mon brave
camille
en revanche air on va penser à consulter
la petite moines ces timbres et pour
bosser avec cyril hanouna pour coup du
design parce qu'il est pas très
équilibré grâce à mon âge au foot tu as
un tout petit peu trop loin en séries la
nouvelle n'est pas quelqu'un d'équilibré
cette personne n'est pas normal bien sûr
que si elle est parfaite donc ça c'est
normal peut-être se taper sur la tête
avec une carte c'est normal tout ça peut
presque classe parce que classé est ce
que tu trouverais ça classe est normal
si un directeur comme les cyril se
comportait exactement comme cyril l'oeuf
à l'antenne mais dans une entreprise
lambda
[Musique]
raconta patrons pat on est au conseil
d'administration
parlons michel klur il est un peu un peu
compliqué pour l'aja
j'avoue je pourrais pas de donner tort à
100 fonctionnaires et ça fait pas
avancer votre affaire pascal humain est
accroché à son poste comme un mort back
aux couilles de jean michel maire
dis moi tu voudrais pas perdre ton âme
il a quand même fait un bon coup de main
ok pourtant vers son halo d'eric c'est
qu'à dire on a une mission pour toi
ouais c'est pas compter sur moi les deux
frères
[Musique]
je reviens je vais voir les deux plus
hautes et pmp way stephen d'éric
bertrand bertrand stephann chanter
c'était femmes merci d'être venu
incessants pas c'est normal ne dit pas
merci je le fais par amitié pour le père
de camille on a grandi ensemble rue
d'aboukir vous avez mis du temps à venir
avoue ok qu'est ce qui s'est passé là ça
roulait mal à tâche revienne chez
dechavanne là j'arrête pas une minute
vous couvre un serment mais relié à la
télé au en tout cas c'est adorable déjà
d'être passé franchement mais le truc
c'est que là on patauge un peu là je ne
vois pas comment on va s'en sortir parce
que on n'est pas aidés et bien sûr que
vous y arriverez pas avant deux
remarques
vous vous y prenez comme des marges [ __ ]
à l'adresse du pâquis moi non j'ai pas
non maintenant dormi chez lui hier ouais
mais je ne prends pas l'adresse en fait
si nous créons des taxis marchier voilà
au quai gillet bamba
mais je m'en foutais d entrain de se
retrouver on avait une mission tous les
deux à allauch camille cali cannes
bon faut se rendre à l'évidence après un
mois de complot c'est la merde camille
est en train de me faire faux bond
derrick n'a servi à rien je sais pas
comment je vais me débarrasser du paquis
seule solution serait de tomber sur
quelqu'un d'assez naïf une bonne poire
qui accepteraient de m'aider au tien
vallée l'impression que la chance me
sourit écoute j'ai quelque chose qui
pourrait intéresser
tu vas me montrer tes seins non mais
j'ai écouté france inter ce matin
j'écoute france inter non j'écoute
europe 1 mais ma voisine elle écoute
france inter donc oui non mais il va
droit au but
et bien ce matin mais au fond je me
demande dans quelle mesure cyril hanouna
ne parle pas aujourd'hui en langue par
l'emploi employant un langage populaire
la langue de villon il ya un siècle de
sa la langue de rabelais de la langue
plus récemment les dates à venir
voilà vous écoutant ce matin non mais
c'est il apporte beaucoup il apporte
beaucoup en france et rabelais non mais
qu'est ce qu'il faut pas entendre ils
sont sérieuses et je te dis que je n'ai
entendu ce matin son mystère en val nom
très sérieux trauma le seul bouquin
qu'il a lu dans sa vie c'est chaud qui
va au cirque et pour lui rappeler ses du
fromage dans le derby de mercy la dérive
mais je vous entends quoi ça peut me
servais abattant à temps parce que à
attend
effectivement c'est très habile valoches
si j'arrive à envoyer paquet l'académie
française je l'aurais plus dans les
pattes à des 8 es à moi la présentation
des pmp bon me reste plus qu'à monter un
comité de soutien pour enrayer le trail
routier l'académie française
dis moi toi il est âgé tu dois connaître
déjà qu'à des missions non bien sûr
regarde pas plus tard qu'hier je dîne
avec d'ormesson web et ses formes il
avait coutume trouve son numéro et de
trois autres numéros et en fait se
débarrasser lui moi je tenais merci fait
quelque chose après l'épisode ce dépôt
[Applaudissements]
est là il serait temps qu'on arrive à
nos fins excuse moi de te le dire
bertrand mais plus les jours passent et
plus tiger de merde c'est très gentil de
ta part camille de te soucier de ma
santé mais ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'émission j'ai passé une folle nuit
d'amour avec valérie bénaïm elle avait
besoin d'amour et de fougue et je vais
donner tout ce qu'elle avait envie de
recevoir et par ailleurs elle m'a donné
un contact qui va nous être fort utile
pour envoyer papa à l'académie française
ouais et tu le verras demain dans
l'épisode scoop du nouveau sinon
concernant un moulin n'est pas sans
savoir qu'on a un problème concernant
les jeux japonais demain soir en direct
sur d8 est bien sage que j'ai envoyé nos
deux meilleurs agents dans la capitale
tokyo pour qui ça
jean-michel mer egée tadese ben oui tu
me parles de deux meilleurs agents cce
d'envoyer la ba ouai ben arfa c'était
les deux discours d'accord tellement
mais apparemment je les ai eus au
téléphone ils devraient pouvoir nous
ramener des yakuzas qui s'occuperait du
comte de série d'anneaux n'abîme
excellent vous habille bien à
l'ascenseur quinze jours
tout ça
notre en place ouais parce qu'on a à
faire et puis j'ai même pas si le poids
séparée de séquences de tournage mari
pour le cinéma
voilà
sa frappe passe
info déjà pêché
verquin et 44,3 me vole ma ale 540 le
nombre de pièces qui est assez fou ça
retrouvez-les états en plus bonjour
chanter non bonjour messieurs
mais là
[Applaudissements]
je t'aime beaucoup camille sauveton
respecter meyers pour du bel accent
pieds noirs que pour nous dégoter des
agents pour se débarrasser de cl je suis
désolé maman entend pas
[Applaudissements]
alain bertrand j'espère que tu as passé
une bonus chez cyril et moi on va chez
cyril maintenant qu'il a pris son envol
mais écoute j'ai passé une excellente
nuit j'ai dormi comme un bébé mais c'est
parce que tu crois c'est pour mieux
m'immiscer moi je crois rien du tout
j'espère simplement vous êtes protégé
c'est tout
d'ailleurs il m'a forcée à écouter
europe 1 ce matin je ne viendra jamais
ce que j'ai entendu je vous cache pas
que je suis très fan d'une émission qui
s'appelle plus pas à mon pote et donc on
a appris aux enfants à danser sur les
airs du et voilà on leur a appris cette
danse on l'a envoyée aux états unis et
demain on va se voir on skype
on va apprendre la danse ensemble on va
apprendre que l'américain a dansé sur
sept dents tu penses à la même chose que
moi qu'émile se mettre du beurre de
cacahuètes sur les couilles
non moi je pensais plutôt à ça
[Musique]
denis d'amérique ça me chauffe ça mais
oui eh ben oui bien sûr et c'est je
pourrais weezy l'envoyer aux états unis
m'a bien sûr pourquoi si le pack pas
très populaire chez les jeunes enfants
américains on lui confie département
d'éducation des états unis et et s'il
n'est pas en france il est aux états
unis donc il est pas en france
donc il ne fait pas chier sur d8 lui
damman sécu ldd donc tu connais barack
obama alors non en revanche je connais
quelqu'un qui connaît quelqu'un qui
connaît barack obama ok tu l'appelles
tout de suite à l'eau laurence haïm
rendez vous demain sur des beats en a
une mission très importante pour vous
[Rires]